Constitution à le règlement vous
espériez sans doute que nous laissions
les retraites des Français entre vos
mains entre les mains des droites
coalisées nous ne sommes pas dupes de
vos manœuvres les Français non plus nous
ne lâcherons rien nous ne les lâcherons
pas merci alors la vie de monsieur le
rapporteur
c'est la vie de la commission des
favorables
du gouvernement défavorable
et nous passons maintenant à l'article
13 mes chers collègues je suis saisi
d'une demande de parole pour le groupe
socialiste madame Annie Le Véro
merci monsieur le Président alors cet
article 13 concerne deux dispositifs
principaux la création de droits à
pension en cumulant un emploi et la
retraite et étendre la retraite
progressive à la fonction publique en
général et aux indépendants alors nous
retrouvons regrettable de ne pouvoir
échanger sur ces deux outils nouveaux
puisque vous avez décidé de dévitaliser
la fonction parlementaire par l'addition
de toutes les procédures que vous offre
la constitution et le règlement vous
espériez sans doute que nous laissions
la retraite des Français entre les mains
des droites coalisées nous ne sommes pas
dupes les Français n'ont plus nous ne
lâcherons rien nous ne les lâcherons pas
pour revenir à cet article 13 la
libéralisation du dispositif cumule en
point retraite vise à faire travailler
les retraités en raison du montant
insuffisant de leur pension de retraite
pour mettre un peu de beurre dans les
épinards de ceux et celles qui ont
travaillé dur et qui n'en peuvent déjà
plus le cumul emploi retraite est
inégalité seuls sont concernées les
personnes qui disposent de
qualifications reconnus durant leur
carrière et qui partent en bonne santé
et avec des pensions déjà correctes et
qui peuvent reprendre facilement une
activité plutôt que de corriger les
inégalités de carrière et notamment
l'égalité salariale entre les femmes et
les hommes cet article risque de
fragiliser encore davantage la santé des
personnes qui vont devoir poursuivre une
activité salariée au-delà de 64 ans
avec vos deux années de travail
obligatoire les personnes qui auront des
carrières pénibles ne pourront plus
travailler comme vous le leur demandez
dans les IAD et Côtes-d'Armor que
pensent des ouvriers les ouvrières que
pensent les aides à domicile sur le
dispositif de cumul en point retraite
alors qu'ils sont déjà cassés à 45 ans
je peux vous dire qu'il n'aspire pas à
un cumul en poids retraite ils
attendaient avec attend impatience de
partir à 62 ans et ils devront attendre
deux années pour y prétendre
hier sont souvent des femmes et elles
demandent une revalorisation salariale
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Jérémy pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre l'article 13 du projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
rectificative aurait mérité un véritable
débat et nous ne pouvons que regretter
de ne pouvoir affronter nos arguments
sur cette disposition en effet l'article
13 prévoit deux mesures au philosophie
opposés d'un côté il favorise et
améliore le recours à la retraite pour
qui permet de partir à 60 ans aux
travailleurs une transition vers la
retraite en réduisant son temps de
travail sans perte de salaire ni perte
de droit à l'impatience de retraite ce
mécanisme qui permet une transition des
seniors vers la retraite doit être
encouragé nous regrettons la complexité
des démarches pour en bénéficier et le
choix des employeurs de préférer souvent
les ruptures conventionnelles à ce
dispositif de maintien dans l'emploi des
seniors ainsi en 2020 seul 23 800 des
salariés bénéficier d'une retraite
progressive de notre côté cet article 13
ouvre des droits pour les retraités qui
décideraient de reprendre le travail en
ayant recours au cumul emploi retraite
sur cette disposition il aurait fallu un
débat sur la conception de la société
que nous voulons voulons-nous une
société où nous aciers accomplissent des
petits boulots pour compléter leur
pension de retraite insuffisante ou
voulons-nous d'une société où les
travailleuses et les travailleurs
financés par les cotisations sociales à
l'assurance vie illes pourrait avoir une
pension digne jusqu'à la fin de leur
jour si les entreprises rémunérées
correctement les salariés si les femmes
étaient payées à compétences et à
post-équivalent aux hommes au même
niveau les retraités ne seraient pas
obligés de devoir travailler ainsi il
faut bien avoir en tête qu'il ne s'agit
pas de retraités qui souhaitent
reprendre une activité professionnelle
mais bel et bien de retraités qui n'ont
pas d'autres choix financièrement je
vous remercie
qui Monsieur Daniel Breuillet
merci monsieur le Président la retraite
progressive est en effet un dispositif
qui pourrait être efficace pour
faciliter la transition vers la retraite
surtout pour les emplois les plus
difficiles même si nous jugeons que le
gouvernement ne va pas assez loin pour
démocratiser améliorer ce dispositif qui
est loin d'être parfait en effet les
retraités ne sont saisissent pas assez
seulement 2% d'entre eux et bien que cet
article vise à changer la donne en
ouvrant ce dispositif au fonctionnaire
et en imposant aux employeurs de
justifier leur refus quand un salarié en
fait la demande nous proposons pour
notre part de rendre impossible pour
l'employeur de refuser une telle demande
et
ça devrait devenir donc un véritable
droit le problème avec ce dispositif
c'est qu'il aurait fallu maintenir cette
possibilité de départ en retrait de
progressive à 60 ans voire même plutôt
pour les carrières longues mais nous ne
partageons pas la philosophie d'ouvrir
la question du cumul emploi retraite qui
visent finalement à considérer que la
vie n'est faite que pour travailler et
que les retraités pauvres auront comme
ça la possibilité de rajouter de mettre
un peu de beurre dans les épinards que
le montant de leur retraite ne permet
pas alors bien que la retraite
progressive soit un élément très utile
pour faciliter la transition vers la
traite nous ne pouvons nous résoudre à
voter un dispositif mais heureusement
nous n'aurons pas le voté puisque vous
avez choisi d'utiliser tous les moyens
que vous donne la Constitution pour
dévitaliser la fonction parlementaire
par l'addition de toutes les procédures
possibles 47 ans 44 38 article 42 vous
espériez sans doute que nous laissions
la retraite des Français entre les mains
des droites coalisées ce ne sera pas le
cas et même si on ne peut plus débattre
même si nous amendements ne seront pas
votés nous pouvons toujours et je vous
en remercie monsieur le Président de
l'avoir souligné retirer nos amendements
et je signale au gouvernement qu'il a
aussi le droit de retirer son projet de
retraite
à l'examen de deux amendements
identiques de suppression de l'article
l'amendement
3381 madame ponce
merci monsieur le Président alors les
réformes des retraites s'enchaînent
toujours avec le même but productiviste
travaillez plus pour gagner des points
de PIB et ces points petits points de
PIB reposent sur les travailleurs et il
repose par l'augmentation là oui sans
fin de leur temps de travail dans la
poursuite de cette logique sans fin nous
discutons donc d'un article qui vise à
favoriser le cumul en point retraite
pour que même en retraite on travaille
et on produise encore et encore l'objet
et je dirais c'est souvent parce que les
gens ils recourt parce que souvent à
cause de la baisse tendancielle du
niveau relatif des pensions l'objet de
l'amendement n'est pas de remettre en
question bien sûr le cumul emploi
retraite c'est un choix ou un droit ce
dont il s'agit c'est d'interroger la
logique sans fond et la poursuite d'une
logique effectivement qui fonce vers le
mur climatique sans aucun questionnement
sur le modèle de production
et bien non l'urgence n'est pas de
travailler plus mais de pouvoir d'avoir
le droit de partir dès 60 ans pour
profiter d'année de repos en bonne santé
cette réforme ce targue de créer 300 000
emplois enfin vainc que créer 300 000
emplois par ce prolongement de deux ans
alors qu'il va aussi produire 200 000
seigneurs qui vont rester dans le sas de
précarité j'aurais bien aimé développé
mais je reçois j'ai reçu un instant un
message de Joël Labbé qui me demande de
de vous lire un message
alors ce message c'est vous avez décidé
de dévitaliser la fonction parlementaire
par l'addition de toutes les procédures
que vous offre la constitution et le
règlement vous espériez sans doute que
nous laissions la retraite des Français
entre les mains des droits de coalisés
nous ne sommes pas dupe les Français
n'ont plus nous ne lâcherons rien nous
ne les lâcherons pas c'était le message
pour conclure
un amendement 4002 rectifier madame
gréaume merci monsieur le Président cet
article 13 prévoit la libéralisation du
dispositif d'emploi retraite qui vise à
faire travailler les retraités en raison
du montant insuffisant de leur pension
de retraite cette mesure a été déjà
présente dans la réforme des retraites
2019 qui prévoyaient durant le cumul
emploi retraite plus avantageux
financièrement et prévoyez d'accorder
des points supplémentaires pour leur
pension ici l'article 13 prévoit la
constitution des droits à pension en
cumulant point retraite qui s'en
trouverait plus élevé la philosophie de
cet article 13 converge avec celle du
projet de loi du gouvernement qui
consiste à faire travailler tout le
monde plus longtemps y compris à partir
du moment où les personnes liquides leur
droit à la retraite notre conception de
la société est à l'opposé nous
souhaitons la retraite pour profiter de
la vie sociale familiale culturelle et
sportive pour s'émanciper bénéficier du
droit au repos et au temps libre
monsieur le ministre j'en profite pour
vous dire que je trouve scandaleux la
LED du 9 mars du président de la
République au syndicat refuse en donc de
les recevoir scandaleux de dire que nous
débattons tous les points de vue dans
cette hémicycle c'est faux votre loi est
injuste et injustifiée le recours au
procédure pour bloquer nos amendements
rendre ce texte illégitime et quel que
soit l'issue de l'examen de ce texte la
bataille pour son retrait se poursuivra
je vous le dis nous ne lâcherons pas et
nous continuerons à soutenir le peuple
qui est dans la rue et qui manifeste
pour son retrait et nous sommes nombreux
merci
alors la vie de la Commission
monsieur le Président mais quel dommage
quel dommage de vouloir supprimer ces
dispositifs de transition on essaie tous
mis dans la réflexion qui nous anime
d'accord pour dire qu'il y avait une
zone une période de transition entre la
fin de la vie active et des vues de la
vie sédentaire et qu'il était important
que la société voit ça différemment à
travers divers dispositifs dont la
retraite progressive et donc cumule
emploi retraite pourquoi voulez-vous que
les personnes qui ont un revenu faible
qui sont en retraite ne puissent pas si
elles ont envie retravailler pourquoi
voulez-vous que des personnes qui font
le choix de retravailler parce que
l'inactivité ne leur convient pas
forcément pourquoi voulez-vous les
priver et puis une chose importante à
rappeler d'encylositive cumule emploi
retraite c'est que qui doit nous faire
réfléchir par rapport aux dispositifs de
retraite anticipée pour carrière longue
20%
de personnes qui bénéficient d'une
carrière anticipée retourne en cumulent
emploi retraite après ça doit quelque
part nous interpeller en ce qui concerne
la retraite progressive c'est une
avancée qui est proposée puisqu'il est
il est proposé à travers cette article
13 de l'étendre en plus des salariés du
privé au fonctionnaire et aux
différentes professions notamment les
professions libérales l’étendre à tous
donc c'est une avancée tout à fait
significative mais nous pensons que dans
le cas de cette réflexion de la
transition entre la partie active et la
partie sédentaire de notre vie il est
peut-être important de pouvoir laisser
ce dispositif de retraite progressive
décevoix cent ans c'est là que nous
avons actuellement une divergence avec
le gouvernement monsieur le ministre
puisque peut-être que il serait
intéressant de l'aménager des 60 ans
avec une quantité de travail
effectivement de 80% pour que ce soit
progressif que là aussi ça ne soit pas
un coup
prohibitif peut-être que nous pouvons
dans ce cadre-là si vous en étiez
d'accord monsieur le ministre aménagé
encore pour que il y ait effectivement
une prise de décision partagée entre le
salarié et l'employeur pour faire en
sorte qu'on arrive à laisser au droit
actuel le départ à 60 ans qui serait
effectivement élargi à l'ensemble du
public et c'est la raison pour laquelle
je comprends votre inquiétude notamment
par rapport à l'élargissement aux
fonctionnaires qui peut être une voie
qui si elle était trop empruntée
pourrait mettre en difficulté également
le fonctionnement de certaines
administrations donc votre inquiétude me
paraît tout à fait légitime et il s'agit
de doser pour que ce soit un objet de
transition qui amène une valeur ajoutée
dans cette période de vie merci Olivier
ministre
merci monsieur le Président la ville de
du gouvernement et évidemment
défavorable sur les amendements de
suppression d'abord nous pensons que le
fait de faciliter l'accès à la retraite
progressive est un progrès le fait de
l'ouvrir aux agents de la fonction
publique et aussi un progrès et une
réponse et une attente exprimée de
depuis longtemps et que ça facilite
finalement la possibilité de lever le
pied si mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs me permettent cette expression
avant de partir à la retraite pour ce
qui concerne le cumulant retraite
permettez-moi une remarque pour dire que
évidemment il y a des retraités qui vont
faire le choix de cumuler la retraite
avec un emploi et d'autres qui dans la
situation qu'ils connaissent n'auront
pas le choix mais mais feront
à travailler pour compléter leurs
revenus c'est d'ailleurs
une manière pour moi de dire que ça ne
concerne pas que les retraités qui ont
des qualifications que les retraités qui
ont des compétences particulières
puisque malheureusement vous le dites
madame Libin il y a des retraités qui
ont des petites retraites et qui doivent
cumuler cette retraite avec des
activités qui ne sont pas nécessairement
des activités très qualifiées on a
peut-être tous en tête celles et ceux
qui livrent tel ou tel prospectus ou
font des activités de service ou de
complément qui permettront d'être
contributive on peut considérer que la
situation initiale et la cause de cela
n'est pas satisfaisante c'est le cas
mais ça ne doit pas nous empêcher je
crois d'apporter un droit à ceux qui par
choix ou par contrainte on accumulé un
emploi avec la retraite la remarque que
je voulais faire sur ce point-là
monsieur le Président concerne peut-être
la précision à apporter sur le fait que
ce que nous vous proposons par la loi
concerne le caractère contributif du
cumulon plein retraite dans le cas du
régime général la loi ne peut se
substituer aux partenaires sociaux pour
faire en sorte que ce cumuler l'emploi
retraite devienne contributif pour les
régimes complémentaires mais sans
préjugés des décisions des partenaires
sociaux et sont évidemment me substituer
à leur responsabilité je pense que c'est
un mouvement que nous initions et qui
serait bienvenue que les régimes
complémentaires alignent aussi leur
règle en matière de capacité
contributive des
du cumul en plein retraite enfin
monsieur le rapporteur a évoqué la
l'ouverture de la retraite progressive à
60 ans plutôt que 62 plutôt plus
exactement quatre ans avant l'âge
d'ouverture des droits plutôt que deux
ans si nous le disons comme cela en
élargissant le disposition proposée par
le gouvernement le coût est de 400
millions d'euros par an si nous le
disons comme monsieur le rapporteur a
écrit en restaignant cette possibilité
au maintien d'une activité
professionnelle à 80% nous sommes entre
130 150 millions d'euros par an et si
nous travaillons sur les règles d'ici la
CMP sur les règles d'autorisation pour
revenir aux règles actuelles si je puis
dire et ne pas appliquer à cette période
entre n-4 et - 2 des règles avec
nécessité de faire la preuve d'une
incompatibilité avec le fonctionnement
d'entreprise on doit certainement
pouvoir trouver quelques quelques
marches si je puis dire et recalibrer ce
dispositif gageons que les discussions
d'ici la CMP permettent d'avancer
merci nous allons examiner un amendement
monsieur le rapporteur
oui c'est un amendement qui vise à
préciser que l'estimation Indicative
Globale adresse et tous les 5 ans aux
assurés à partir de 55 ans inclut
également des informations sur les
règles applicables aux fonctionnaires en
matière de cumul emploi retraite
avis du gouvernement
ensuite trois amendements
identiques
le 25 22 d'abord qui est présenté par
Monsieur le Président compta
252 merci monsieur le Président d'abord
j'ai également reçu un message de ma
collègue Monique de Marco qui se pose
aussi la question et qui me demande
pourquoi vous avez décidé de dévitaliser
la fonction parlementaire par l'addition
de toutes les procédures que vous offre
la constitution et le règlement vous
espériez sans doute que nous laissions
la retraite des Français entre les mains
des droites coalisées nous ne sommes pas
dupe les Français non plus nous ne
lâcherons rien nous ne lâcherons pas
cette cette amendement déposé par le
groupe écologiste donc vise à mettre en
lumière l'inégalité du dispositif du
cumul emploi retraite pour de nombreuses
personnes qui craignent de ne pas
pouvoir conserver leur niveau de vie
après la fin de leur activité
professionnelle le cumul emploie
retraite peut sembler être une option
séduisante ce maintenant elle met en
réalité cruellement en lumière le fait
que le montant des pensions de retraite
est insuffisant de plus ce cumul emploi
retraite est un dispositif profondément
inégalitaire car il s'adresse
essentiellement aux personnes qui
disposent de qualifications reconnus
durant leur carrière qui partent en
bonne santé et avec des pensions
correctes et qui à ce titre peuvent
prétendre plus facilement une activité
on a pu voir selon l'Insee que les
bénéficiaires de ce dispositif de cumul
emploi retraite sont en majorité des
personnes qui ont des carrières
complètes des emplois de cadre et des
pensions de retraite supérieure à la
moyenne alors que cet article du projet
de loi vise à rendre le cumul emploi
retraite créateur de droit nous pensons
que la priorité est plutôt de corriger
les inégalités de carrière qui concerne
particulièrement les femmes et
d'augmenter le montant des pensions dans
le c'est chiant ce dispositif va
seulement finir par précariser un peu
plus les retraités qui touchent de
faibles pensions et qui seront forcés de
continuer à occuper un emploi salarié
après l'âge de 64 ans une fois encore
cet article montre que le gouvernement
naissait en aucun cas de redire des
inégalités comme il le répète depuis le
10 janvier dernier puisque sa réforme a
juste les brutale ne contient en aucun
cas des mesures qui amélioreront le
quotidien de français des Français bien
au contraire le but est bien de pousser
les Français les plus précaires à
travailler plus longtemps via
l'intégration du dispositif de cumul
emploi retraite merci Monsieur Merci
le monde madame le héros
le président je voudrais vous rappeler
combien nous sommes nous regrettons que
vous ayez décidé avec Monsieur le
Ministre de dévitaliser la fonction
parlementaire par l'addition de toutes
les procédures que vous offre la
constitution et le règlement vous
espériez sans doute que nous laissions
la retraite des Français entre les mains
des droites coalisées nous ne sommes pas
dupes les Français non plus nous ne
lâcherons rien et nous ne les lâcherons
pas alors
concernant le cumul emploi retraite
seuls les personnes qui ont des
qualifications et qui partent en bonne
santé sont concernés par la question du
cumul emploi retraite et le reportage à
64 ans limite l'intérêt de ce dispositif
en lieu et place de renforcer la lutte
contre les inégalités l'esprit de cette
mesure fragilise des personnes qui vont
devoir continuer à travailler l'enjeu de
l'emploi des seniors n'est pas le cumul
emploi retraite mais le maintenir dans
l'emploi des salariés âgés or rien dans
cette réforme
hormis un index senior à 60 ans je
voulais rappeler qu'une personne sur
trois n'est ni en emploi ni à la
retraite la majorité d'entre elles sont
en invalidité au RSA ou au chômage et
ces personnes vivent souvent en
précarité avec votre deux années
supplémentaires de travail obligatoire
les personnes qui auront des carrières
pénibles ne pourront plus travailler
plus comme vous le demandez nous aurions
souhaité une loi travail sur l'emploi
des seniors le vieillissement au travail
l'adaptation des conditions de travail à
des fins de carrière aurait dû être
votre priorité nous ne le répéterons
jamais assez agir sur le taux d'emploi
des seniors et l'égalité salariale Femme
Homme sont des solutions de financement
assez retraite tout levier que le
gouvernement a laissé de côté pour faire
porter au travailleur tous les efforts
d'une réforme brutale elle justifiée et
injuste merci
merci monsieur le Président nous
souhaitons la suppression de l'alinéa 6
de l'article 13 pour les mêmes raisons
que nous demandons la suppression de
l'article le cumul emploi retraite est
un dispositif inégalitaire car il
s'adresse essentiellement aux personnes
qui disposent de qualifications
reconnues durant leur carrière qui
partent en bonne santé avec des pensions
correctes et à qui ce titre peuvent
reprendre plus facile et à ce qui à ce
titre peuvent reprendre plus facilement
une activité selon l'Insee les
bénéficiaires actuels du système du
cumul emploi retraite sont ainsi
majoritairement des personnes qui ont
des carrières complètes ou des niveaux
de pension supérieurs à la moyenne
plutôt que de corriger les inégalités de
carrière qui concernent particulièrement
les femmes cet article risque de
fragiliser encore davantage les
personnes qui vont devoir poursuivre une
activité salariée au-delà de 64 ans
celles et ceux qui ont recours au cumul
emploi retraite sont les mêmes que
celles et ceux qui travaillent au-delà
62 ans pour bénéficier de la sur ce sont
les salariés dans la rémunération ne
permet pas de retraite digne ils doivent
trouver des solutions pour avoir une
pension suffisante pour faire face à la
hausse des prix du quotidien et des
coups des soins non remboursés par la
Sécurité sociale alors voilà encore un
amendement qui ne pourra avoir de suite
puisque vous avez décidé de dévitaliser
la fonction parlementaire par l'addition
de toutes les procédures que vous offre
la constitution et le règlement vous
expiriez sans doute que nous laissions
la retraite des Français entre les mains
des droites coalisées nous ne sommes pas
dupes les Français non plus nous ne
lâcherons rien oui et nous ne les
la alors invite la Commission
si monsieur le Président quelques
minutes sur la vie il sera global à la
fois pour ses amendements de suppression
qui demandent la modification de
l'intitulé donc c'est pas d'une grande
utilité me semble-t-il donc ce sera un
avis bien sûr défavorable et puis les
suivants également qui demandent de le
supprimer mais aussi le corps humain
l'emploi retraite moi je vous comprends
pas là il y a quelque chose qui va pas
vous parler des petites retraites vous
êtes les défenseurs de ceux qui ont des
petites retraites alors pourquoi
voulez-vous priver ces gens-là du cumul
emploi retraite c'est pour ceux qui
l'ont actuellement ça va ouvrir des
droits ils pourront reliquider derrière
leur retraite et améliorer plus tard
leur retraite
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas est-ce que
vous ne pensez pas
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas que ça
peut rendre service à ces personnes
voilà premièrement
ceux qui sont actuellement en emploi
retraite pour en bénéficier deuxièmement
ce qui concerne les petites retraites
mais ça nous interpelle mes chers
collègues c'est pour ça qu'on propose
une réforme je vous rappelle je vous
rappelle quand même s'il vous plaît je
vous rappelle que le niveau moyen des
retraités actuellement en France c'est
103% par rapport au niveau des du
salaire moyen et que les prévisions du
corps dont vous parlez tant dont vous
faites des interprétations conduisent
toutes conduisent toutes à une baisse de
la pension moyenne dans les années qui
viennent ce sera 85%, ce sera plus en
3%, c'est pour ça qu'il faut réformer ce
système et quelle est la mesure qui
permet de faire en sorte que de façon
moyenne on est une meilleure retraite
mais c'est la borne d'âge parce qu'on
sait bien que l'allongement de la durée
de cotisation conduit à un niveau moyen
de retraite qui n'est pas en augmentant
par contre c'est l'abordonnage qui fait
qu'il y a un meilleur revenu c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous vous c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous sommes
particulièrement 106 à ce niveau de
retraite et que le seul moyen de faire
en sorte que cette retraite qui dure de
plus en plus longtemps ne soit pas une
retraite de pauvres c'est de prendre des
mesures qu'on propose merci la vie la
vie du gouvernement
la vie du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le Président la vie des
favorable sur les amendements de
suppression comme il sera défavorable
sur les amendements suivants qui
suppriment une partie de cet article à
l'exception bien sûr du 21 67 il n'a pas
encore été présenté mais qui est
rédactionnel je précise pour la bonne
information de tous que le cumul emploi
retraite sera contributif avec un
caractère légèrement rétroactif puisque
nous intégrerons dans ce caractère
contributif les activités exercées si la
loi est adoptée bien sûr à compter du
1er janvier 2023 donc de toute l'année
monsieur le Président guitare voulait
faire un rappel réglement je crois qu'il
faut respecter le principe du rappel
réglement mais je vous donne la parole
allez oui merci merci monsieur le
Président effectivement le principe du
rappel au Règlement sur sur le champ qui
est accordé sur le champ je suis
d'accord et sur la l'article 44 bis et
sur la sincérité des débats
je vois et d'ailleurs je voudrais
remercier le rapporteur parce qu'on voit
toute sa frustration
sa grande frustration aujourd'hui et
depuis hier parce que il a envie du
débat il a envie de débattre il a envie
d'exprimer ses arguments et on voit
d'ailleurs toute la beauté dans cette
hémicycle quand il y a ce débat mais
hélas vous en avez décidé autrement
ensemble avec le gouvernement vous avez
décidé ce 44-3 et donc ce débat ne peut
pas avoir lieu
ces regrettable c'est très embêtant mais
donc je vous demanderai et je vous
demanderai très personnellement de à la
fois de ne pas nous poser de questions
puisque nous ne pouvons pas répondre
vous a décidé qu'il n'y aurait pas de
débat donc faites en sorte que le débat
n'est pas lieu merci alors 4 amendements
qui vont faire l'objet d'une discussion
commune l'abonnement 4010 monsieur lelec
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
mes chers collègues
en vérité je vous le dis
je vous le redis vous avez décidé de
déviatiser la fonction parlementaire par
l'adhésion le par l'addition de toutes
les procédures dont vous disposez
vous espériez sans doute que nous
laissions les retraites entre vos mains
nous ne sommes pas dupes les Français
non plus nous ne lasserons rien nous ne
lâcherons absolument rien
alors
cet amendement vise au fond à remettre
en cause les alinéens 18 à 39
en effet le gouvernement propose de
modifier le dispositif à l'emploi de
tête en permettant l'acquisition de
nouveaux droits à la retraite lorsque le
cumul est réalisé après le départ à taux
plein et après liquidation de toute des
pensions
cette mesure peut apparaître comme une
bonne chose monsieur le rapporteur en
ouvrant des droits pour celles et ceux
qui reprennent une activité
professionnelle
mais aujourd'hui le cumul en voie
retraite s'adresse essentiellement à
celles et ceux qui ont eu des métiers
les moins pénibles mais surtout en
prévoyant l'ouverture de droit dès lors
que les salariés disposent d'une
carrière complète on oublie quand même
un peu les femmes en effet les emplois
du temps partiels sont occupés à 80% par
des femmes qui subissent des carrières
hachées par des arrêts elles sont
environ 20% à attendre l'annulation
automatique de la décote à 67 ans pour
ouvrir leurs droits ce dispositif crédit
une distorsion inéquitable inéquitable
pour les salariés qui n'auraient pas une
carrière complète et le plus souvent des
femmes voilà le sens de l'amendement que
nous proposons
[Applaudissements]
merci
et l'amendement 44
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mais mes chers collègues
monsieur le rapporteur vous nous avez
posé beaucoup de questions elles sont
elles sont intéressantes et on aurait
aimé que on puisse disposer justement
des changes plus fournis pour avoir un
dialogue plus plus au fond ce que ce que
je tenais à vous dire Monsieur monsieur
le rapporteur c'est deux choses la
première c'est que nous sommes
absolument pas contre les dispositifs de
transition bien au contraire le problème
est ce que nous dénonçons c'est les
systèmes subis le temps partiel subit
comme le cumulon point retraite suit et
c'est ça le problème et vous le savez
bien et vous nous dites que votre
retraite votre réforme pardon va mieux
organiser le système de retraite et va
fermer et va permettre des retraites
plus complètes mais dans ces cas-là
votre votre système de transition risque
d'être frappé
d'une quasi obsolescence puisque plus
les retraites seront complètes moins les
gens auront besoin de cumuler avec leur
emploi donc ce que vous nous proposez
finalement c'est une finalité c'est à
dire c'est vers l'extinction du
dispositif de de du cumulon-poit
retraite
merci ce que ce que je voudrais vous
mettre en garde c'est le système
américain le système américain vous avez
quasiment 30% des retraités qui dans les
cinq premières années continuent une
activité pourquoi c'est pas pour le
plaisir il s'agit pas d'un problème de
liberté c'est parce qu'ils n'ont pas les
moyens de continuer à vivre avec leur
simple leur simple retraite et ça c'est
un modèle de société que nous ne voulons
pas merci monsieur le Président alors un
abonnement ensuite
4000 16
madame linman
oui chers collègues oui oui vous avez
décidé de défitaliser la fonction
parlementaire par l'addition de toutes
les procédures que vous offre la
constitution et le règlement je vais les
rappeler
47 ans article 38 du Règlement
44,3
et si j'écoute le président de la
République qui ne veut pas recevoir les
syndicats ce qui est quand même
l'ensemble des syndicats quel mépris il
peut avoir en leur direction mais qui en
plus nous donne des grandes leçons sur
il faudra aller au terme de la démarche
parlementaire en excluant aucune des
mesures constitutionnelles dont le 49.3
c'est à dire que là l'artillerie lourde
elle est totalement anti parlementaire
anti débat anti-démocratique et là ça
devient extrêmement grave
pour l'image de notre pays pour l'image
de la démocratie et de la République
envers nos concitoyens alors vous
expérimentez vous espériez que nous
allions vous laisser
la retraite aux mains des droites
coalisées nous ne sommes pas dupe les
Français n'ont plus et il ne lâcheront
rien et nous ne lâcherons pas nous ne
lâcherons pas non plus le débat sur
nous ne lâcherons pas non plus le débat
sur l’hypocrisie des mesures que vous
présentez comme des pseudos avancés
c'est le fameux pâté cheval à l'ouest et
encore c'est même une demi à Louette et
un cheval et demi c'est à dire que
grosso modo tout ce que vous engagez
c'est pour vous dispenser de constater
les dégâts de ce que vous avez engrangé
dans cette proposition à savoir la
baisse des retraites faut conclure la
baisse des retraites l'allègement des
carrières la difficulté à vous de
pouvoir vivre dignement de sa retraite
en colmatant avec l'emploi
alors monsieur le rapporteur
un amendement rédactionnel monsieur le
président
la vie sur les amendements présentés
monsieur le rapporteur
la vie défavorable sauf sur mon
amendement bien sûr où je me rendrai un
avis je pardon mais je donne pas d'avis
défavorable sur mon âme mais ma vie du
gouvernement
dernier abonnement monsieur le
rapporteur 2168
voilà là aussi ces amendements qui
effectivement propose un aménagement de
la retraite progressive à partir de 60
ans avec des dispositions particulières
c'est un amendement très important
monsieur le Président oui avec des
dispositions particulières pour
délai entre 60 et 62 ans je rappelle que
le droit actuel c'est 60 ans pour les
salariés et les proposer pour la
retraite progressive de passer à 62 ans
pour tout public en conséquence
effectivement il faut peut-être si nous
mettons en place ce dispositif 4 ans
avant l'âge légal l'adapter par une
quantité de travail le rester dans le
droit actuel en ce qui concerne les
acceptations de de ce travail à temps
partiel de façon à ce que la mesure est
vous l'avez précisé monsieur le ministre
est un impact qui ne soit pas trop
important par rapport à notre souci
d'équilibre de cette réforme des
des retraites donc j'attends de vous
monsieur le ministre prendre en compte
ce fait nouveau ce serait peut-être
intéressant ça aiderait notamment ceux
qui ont une usure professionnelle des
gens anticipés qui sont dans un
dispositif qui n'est pas un dispositif
de carrière longue de pouvoir
tranquillement continuer jusqu'à la fin
de leur carrière merci
merci monsieur le Président le
gouvernement n'a pas retenu cet
amendement dans la liste de ceux
auxquels il lui a donné un avis
favorable pour les raisons que j'ai
évoqué en réponse à la discussion art
sur article donc je souscris la
perspective de travailler plus avant
pour voir si les choses sont possibles
la raison qui nous a amené à ne pas
donner un naïf favorable et une raison
budgétaire pour l'équilibre du système
et donc on nous allons regarder cela
d'ici la réunion de la commission mixte
paritaire si d'aventure les membres de
cette commission souhaitaient avancer
sur ce débat je profite de cette prise
de parole pour apporter simplement une
précision et peut-être lever à
malentendu notamment pour ce qui
concerne la retraite progressive j'ai
entendu que ça pouvait rendre difficile
l'accès à une carrière complète je t'ai
bien précisé que lorsqu'on est dans un
système de retraite progressive et que
l'on continue à travailler à temps
partiel tout en ayant liquidé
partiellement sa pension de retraite on
continue à cotiser ça permet de
décélérer sans mettre en danger le fait
d'avoir une carrière complète et donc
sans s'exposer à une décote lors de la
totale c'est un point qui est important
et cela ne contredit pas ou en tout cas
ça ne m'est pas en cause le calcul de la
pension pour les agents publics nous y
veillerons évidemment pas calculé la
pension sur le temps partiel de la
dernière année au des deux dernières
années et pour les assurer au régime
général ça relève aussi d'un arbitrage
personnel puisque le fait de retenir les
25 meilleures années évidemment si un
assuré est à temps partiel les deux
dernières années c'est deux dernières
années ne seront vraisemblablement pas
dans les 25 meilleurs mais je tiens à le
préciser ça n'empêche pas d'atteindre
une carrière complète et c'est même une
façon parce que l'activité est allégée
en temps c'est une façon de permettre
l'accès à une carrière complète avant
l'âge de départ peut-être plus
facilement que dans d'autres situations
merci je vais maintenant suspendre la
séance elle sera reprise à 14h30 pour la
suite de l'examen du texte la séance est
suspendue